dimanche après midi c'est le moment où
tu récupères de ta soirée de la veille
devant un bon film mais pas pour cette
poignée sportif qui bravent le froid et
la pluie alors serre sont en plastique
tuyaux de pvc balle de volée cache donc
cette diableries eux c'est les golden
boys l'équipe de quidditch dijonnaise
alors si vous avez passé les dix
dernières années dans une grotte de
quidditch c'est le sport de la saga
harry potter
sauf qu'ici c'est du coup dietsch moldus
alors la différence
on respecte en gros la fiction
sauf qu'on vole pas bien sûr et ouais
effectivement il ne vole pas mais ils
ont quand même des ballets c'était
manche en plastique popularisé aux états
unis lit à 15 ans le sport est arrivé en
france depuis quelques années sport de
contact mixte ça mérite d'être précisée
c'est un savant mélange entre handball
rugby et basket photos sur les débuts de
l'équipe et de l'association
alors les golden holtz existe depuis
quatre ans mais l'équipe depuis cinq
aujourd'hui ils sont plus d'une
vingtaine de joueurs avec chacun son
rôle et sa spécialité
on va voir plusieurs postes qui sont
vraiment définir et délimiter et
poursuit vers donc c'est ce qu'ils vont
marquer les buts le gardien donc le
gardien c'est un pur suiveurs sauf que
dans la zone en fait autour de ces
anneaux il va voir quelques règles
supplémentaires les batteurs là c'est
vraiment à ce qu'il a de la dynamique du
score et en plus de ça on va voir
l'attrapeur c'est celui qui doit
attraper donc le vif d'or ok alors en
plus de ces quatre postes le coup dit se
joue avec trois types de balle les
cognard les soifs lviv d'or on vous
avoue que sur le coup et ben on n'a pas
tout compris la recherche google des
règles du quidditch s'est imposée est là
c'est le drame non on déconne en
quelques minutes avec un peu de bonne
volonté les règles de base se
comprennent facilement
par contre est-ce qu'il faut vraiment
être fan d'harry potter pour courir un
dimanche d'hiver sous la pluie c'est mon
ami qui est venu le chercher il m'a dit
on va faire du quick
j'ai trouvé ça tellement bizarre que je
suis laissé porter au jeu et sans être
fan d'harry potter j'ai tout de suite
adhéré maintenant c'est vraiment parce
que ses fans s'étaient fait c'est
vraiment fun s'est pas calmée le foot où
tu as tout mis à l'écart un peu excité
pas trop sportive comme soi même quand
t'es pas bon c'est pas grave on donne
quand même ta chance ce jour là ils
n'étaient pas nombreux mais vraiment
motivé on a même eu le droit à de belles
actions alors des potes une passion des
valeurs c'est quoi au final l'esprit
quidditch c'est le coin le kws
c'est la contraction de quidditch et
love en gros toujours presse mettre une
bonne année sur le terrain mais sans
oublier l'essentiel se retrouver tous
ensemble et partager des moments de
douceur et d'amitié
[Musique]